TONIGHT, ERIC HOLDER'S EARLY
PUSH TELLS US ANYTHING ABOUT
WHICH DIRECTION THE DEMOCRATS
ARE HEADED.
>> THE FIRST IN THE NATION'S
PRIMARY STATE GOT A VISIT FROM
A OBAMA A LUM.
>> THERE IS ASSUMPTIONS.
>> ERIC HOLDER TOLD BUSINESS
LEADER AND ACTIVITY IN NEW
HAMPSHIRE TODAY THAT HIS
ANNOUNCEMENT ABOUT 2020 WILL
COME IN THE EARLY PART OF 2019.
>> WHAT I SAID ABOUT THE
PRESIDENCY IS THAT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT I AM CONSIDERING.
>> HOLDER WAS THE FIRST
AFRICAN-AMERICAN ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND ALSO THE FIRST
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO BE HELD IN
CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS WHEN HE
DIDN'T COOPERATE WITH THE FAST
AND FURIOUS.
AND HE WOULD BE A FIRST- TIME
CANDIDATE.
>> I NEVER RUN FOR ELECTED
OFFICE.
>> THE RECENTLY RELEASED COMEY
MEMOS CRITICIZED HOLDER AND
OBAMA BECOMING TOO FRIENDLY WITH
EACH.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP REGRETTED
HIRING THE CURRENT ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
HOLDER PROTECTED THE PRESIDENT
AND I HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR
THAT.
THAT APPEARANCE OF CLOSENESS
WILL BE CRITICAL.
>> HE'S NOT A HOUSEHOLD NAME TO
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS AND THAT IS
A BIG CHALLENGE.
BUT HE WILL TRY TO RIDE THE
OBAMA WAVE.
THERE IS IT A LOT OF NOSTA LJA
FOR OBAMA.
>> TWO GUYS FROM QUEENS, THAT
WOULD BE INTERESTING.
YOU KNOW, NEW YORKERS, THEY KNOW
HOW TO TALK TO OTHER NEW
YORKERS.
NDEMOCRATIC PRIMARY VOTERS
OVERWHELMINGLY WENT FROM BERNIE